Darth Vader story has been incorporated
into every aspect of the Star Wars saga
from films to shows comics and books so
now it's time to chart his entire course
from an enslaved boy on Tatooine to the
inspiration for the galaxy's current
reigning big bad this is Darth Vader
story explained for decades before he
walked on to Princess Leia's ship as the
embodiment of the evil empire when
audiences got the first glimpse of Darth
Vader Anakin Skywalker was born on
Tatooine as a child of a slave woman
named Shmi Skywalker when the Jedi
Master qui-gon jinn asked me about the
boy's father years later she simply told
him that there wasn't one leading
qui-gon to deduce Anakin had been
conceived by the force entities known as
midi-chlorians there it hasn't been
conclusively stated as heavily implied
in both the film and the comics that
Anakin's conception was caused by the
manipulations of the Sith Lord Darth
Plagueis and his apprentice Darth
Sidious
Anakin showed tremendous intelligence
and skill from a very young age and was
so adept at mechanics and repairs that
he built a protocol droid c-3po for void
turn 10 he was also a skilled pod racer
making him a rarity as human reflexes
were usually too slow to allow them to
survive in the sports which drew the
attention of a pair of Jedi Knights
after learning about Anakin's curious
parentage and testing his midi-chlorian
count qui-gon became convinced of
Anakin's potential as a Jedi with
cweigand encouragement
Anakin won his freedom in a pod race and
accompany qui-gon and obi-wan to
Coruscant sadly having to leave his
mother behind qui-gon took anakim before
the Jedi High Council convinced that the
boy could be the chosen one who would
bring balance to the force
masters Yoda and mace windu were wary of
Anakin's age and his fearful demeanor
but quite completed for the opportunity
to train him anyway in the Battle of
Naboo
Anakin piloted a Starfighter against the
Trade Federation proving that his Jedi
reflexes and skill Erza pilots extended
beyond podracing
after the battle was over he discovered
that qui-gon have been killed at the
hands of Darth Maul and obi-wan made a
vow to train Anakin himself in keeping
with his lost masters wishes the High
Council consented and Anakin became a
Jedi Padawan
Anakin spend the next decade training as
Obi Wan's apprentice and proved himself
as an immensely skilled Jedi
also had a tendency towards recklessness
as a young man he reconnected with then
senator Padme Amidala on Coruscant when
he and obi-wan were tasked with guarding
her life after an assassination attempt
we will find out who's trying to kill
you Padme I promise you we will not
exceed our mandate my young padawan
learner wallow be one sought to track
down the people behind the attempt on
pubmed's life Anakin stay behind us her
personal bodyguard and escorted her back
to Naboo the senator and the Jedi soon
fell in love at Anakin stark a
tendencies intruded as he became
tormented by visions of his mother with
Padme at her side Anakin traveled to
Tatooine where he learned that are now
married and free to me Skywalker have
been abducted by Tusken Raiders
Anakin tracked down that Susskind tribe
and his mother who died in his arms
after seeing him one last time in a rage
Skywalker slaughtered the entire tribe
and vowed to Padme that he would become
powerful enough to prevent the people he
loved from dying beginning his descent
into darkness after the Tuscan Raider
incident Anakin and Padme left Tatooine
to rescue obi-wan he'd been taken
prisoner by separatists
unfortunately they like obi-wan was soon
captured by separatist leader Sith Lord
and former Dracula Count Dooku and
sentenced to death in a gladiatorial
arena as they tried to fight their way
out alongside the Jedi reinforcements
arrived in the form of a clone army that
had been discovered by obi-wan under the
leadership of Yoda and mace Windu they
defeated the separatists in what would
become the first battle of the Clone
Wars
with the battle still raging Anakin and
obi-wan engaged Dooku in a lightsaber
duel but Anakin's recklessness got the
better of him when he tried to fight
Dooku alone thesethe defeated Anakin
cutting off Anakin's right arm before
being defeated by Yoda in the days are
followed Anakin and Padme were married
in secret with the Droid c-3po and r2d2
serving as witnesses because the Jedi
Order forbade such romantic attachments
as the Clone Wars gained intensity
Anakin was promoted to Jedi Knights and
became a key general for the Republic
his abilities and competence grew but so
did his recklessness and by extension
his fear of losing those he loved in an
effort to help Yoda suggested honor King
could learn how to let go of people by
taking on an apprentice of his own who
had one day ascends beyond his training
he was paired with a young padawan
named ahsoka tano and while the two
initially had friction due to Asoka's
feisty nature they ultimately became
friends Master if you've taught me one
thing is that nothing is easy when you
are around
ahsoka rose in prominence alongside her
master as awards went on until she was
framed and arrested for a bombing at the
Jedi Temple that was actually carried
out by one of her friends
ahsoka was expelled from the Jedi Order
but Anakin and Padme believed in her
innocence and were ultimately able to
gain evidence that led to her acquittal
at trial though she was offered wee
admission to the ranks of the Jedi
ahsoka was disillusioned after her trial
and she chose to leave the Jedi behind
witnessing the treatment of his former
apprentice only served a further four
straight Anakin who was beginning to
lose faith in the Jedi High Council by
the end of the Clone Wars Anakin's
growing abilities and his purported
status as the chosen one caught the
attention of the Sith Lord Darth Sidious
Sidious was manipulating the entire war
from behind the scenes via his dual
roles as a Sith and a sheev Palpatine
yes that's his first name the Chancellor
of the Republic
Palpatine finally made his move on
Skywalker in the waning days of the war
urging him to kill Dooku in cold blood
in the midst of space above Khorasan
Anakin complied decapitating Dooku and
Palpatine continued grooming Anakin as
his agent by appointing him that is
emissary to the Jedi Council the council
submits it to the Chancellor's wishes
but they refused to grant Anakin the
rank of master further in flaming his
frustrations though obi-wan continue to
champion him I have trained you since
you were a small boy I have taught you
everything I know and you have become a
far greater Jedi than I could ever hope
to be
unfortunately the denial of Anakin's
knighthood coupled with his frequent
visions of Padme who was then pregnant
dying in despair led Palpatine to
finally reveal himself to Anakin
convincing him that he could stop the
death of his loved ones by using the
dark side of the force
conflicted Anakin first revealed that
Palpatine was a Sith Lord and then
helped Palpatine kill mace windu in the
hopes of learning how to save Padme
though distressed by his betrayal of the
Jedi Anakin submitted himself to his new
master who in turn dubbed him Darth
Vader Palpatine despatched Vader to the
Jedi Temple as part of his great Jedi
purge by Vader brutally slaughtered any
force user in his path
including the children by
then journey to the fiery planet Mustafa
with obi-wan and Padme having learned of
his betrayal following to stop him
enraged by the idea that his old master
and his wife are working together to
betray him he used a force to choke
Padme into unconsciousness that engaged
ob1 in at all ultimately obi-wan gained
the high ground in the fights severed
both of Vader's legs and left him near a
lava ditch to die Palpatine saved his
apprentice then outfitted him in a
life-preserving suit of armor
transforming him into the half machine
Vader we all know and love
Palpatine also told Vader that had
accidentally killed Padme and their
unborn child back on Mustafar
in truth bad mayor died of a broken
heart but not before secretly giving
birth to Anakin's twin children Luke and
Leia who were hidden away from him as
they grew up Vader then took his place
at Palpatine site as a republic became
the Galactic Empire although he still
harbored a desire to bring Padme back at
all costs two decades passed as the
Empire continued to rise and Vader
continued his efforts to eradicate the
remaining Jedi he also had to deal with
Palpatine schemes to encourage his
competitive nature by drafting other
warriors who could serve as faders for
placement at the Emperor's site it was
during this era that Palpatine gifted
Vader a mask belonging to momen an
ancient Sith Lord and artist whose
spirit still possessed the mask Vader
use a gateway opened by moment to search
for Padme spirits and bring her back but
instead he found darkness as her form
disintegrated before his eyes Vader came
out of the experience convinced that
both Padme and Anakin Skywalker were
dead and that his past no longer
mattered while Vader pursued his own
interests a revolutionary movement
formed blossoming into the Rebel
Alliance a group which sought to wage
all-out war against the Empire
in those early days ahsoka tano joined
the alliance dueling Vader to be what he
believed to be her death their rebellion
gained an unexpected advantage 19 years
after the fall of the Republic when it
managed to seize her plans to a planet
destroying battle station called the
desta Vader led the pursuit of the
rebels and managed to capture one of
their leaders princess leia organa who
and beknownst to him was his long-lost
daughter after destroying layers adopted
planet of Alderaan Vader then had an
unexpected encounter with an old friend
when a small group that included obi-wan
Kenobi infiltrated the Death Star to
rescue Leia the master in the approach
just decided it was time for a rematch
this time there was no high ground and
Vader killed his old teacher but the
rescue was successful and the rebels
were clear - you too Death Star plans to
attack in the ensuing battle Vader
almost killed rebel pilots Luke
Skywalker is still a known long lost son
he would go on to destroy the Death Star
and give the Alliance their first big
victory after learning of Luke's true
identity through his agents Vader
finally tracked down his Sunna - hidden
base on the ice planet Hoth while the
rebels escaped a pulp a team of the
oldest knowledge of Luke - Vader and the
two began working to bring the younger
Skywalker over to the dark side
Vader captured Luke's friends han and
Leia using them as bait to lure Luke
away from his training with Yoda who had
been living in hiding for the past two
decades the plan works and Luke arrived
on Bespin to battle Vader and save his
friends Vader defeated the young Jedi in
a lightsaber duel severing Luke's right
hand in the process and revealing that
he was Luke's father instead of joining
the dark side he decided to fall to his
death instead but was rescued by Leia
and the Falcon Vader returned from
Bespin to help oversee construction of a
second Death Star planning with the
emperor to use a new super weapon as
bait to ensnare and defeat the rebellion
by making it look more vulnerable than
it was Luke we emerged on the forest of
Endor allowing himself to be captured
and taken to the desta he was determined
to redeem Vader just as Vader was
determined to convert his son by
bringing him before the emperor drawing
the door that followed Vader sensed in
his son's mind that he had a sister
Vader second child and to use this
knowledge to draw out Luke's anger
rather than giving in to the dark side
though Luke tossed his weapon aside this
didn't sit well with Palpatine who was
funded by using Force Lightning to
electrocute Luke watching his son die
something suddenly switched inside Vader
weakened wounded Vader managed to throw
his master into the core of the Death
Star with his dying breath Anakin
Skywalker returned from the dark side
and told his son that he was right about
him all along
the rebels victory at a second Death
Star marked the beginning of the end for
the Galactic Empire betas legacy is a
dark side legend lived on however and
took a route again in the form of his
grandson Leia and Han scared Ben solo
Bank or the eye of Snoke a powerful dark
side user and skull
who sense the dark side potential in the
Skywalker bloodline and he sought to
cultivate it within Ben he succeeded and
Ben solo rose up against his uncle Jedi
Master Luke Skywalker ending Luke's
attempt to rebuild the Jedi Order when
he finally turned to the dark side Ben
solo changed his name to kylo Ren and
failed to finish Fatah's mission to
eradicate the Jedi he even acquired
Vader's old helmets which had been
partially burned in his funeral pyre
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Star Wars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and to the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]